donc au plan économique on l'a dit
en chiffres c'est 80 millions de
journées de travail qui s'en trouvent
affectés soit un préjudice obamo de 1
milliard 200 millions par an
et il faut pas oublier qu'en fait les
médicaments
notamment antalgiques en particulier
parce que vous pouvez plus conduire
votre véhicule vous pouvez plus aller au
travail et
il faut bien dire aujourd'hui que les
morts finis que sont prescrits en
première ligne et pas seulement les
morphiniques les psychotropes parce que
bien souvent les médecins qui sont en
première ligne les médecins généralistes
sont démunis face à des patients
douloureux chroniques qui ne trouvent
pas de débouchés dans les centres de la
douleur chronique avec seulement 3% des
patients douloureux chroniques qui
peuvent trouver une place dans ces
centres de la douleur chronique qui sont
sur saturé